hey we're gonna I want to look at at the
Western Conference and one thing that I
miss I miss a lot of things but I miss
using the post-it notes that that that
we we did with bold predictions so
here's a chance for some of you guys to
give me a bold prediction when you look
at the Western Conference standings and
the teams that are here and obviously
Portland they're three and a half behind
Memphis as they try to get into that top
eight or at least get into that play and
if they're within four games of the
Grizzlies and then there were others who
were in that mix as well when you get
down to New Orleans and Sacramento and
San Antonio San Antonio it's been to the
playoffs 22 years in a row so that is in
jeopardy Phoenix hasn't been since 2010
and there's six games out so tell me if
9 10 11 12 or 13 is going to make the
playoffs who's gone can I go you got
jack
so the shot and we'll get in the
playoffs Portland will get in the
playoffs Portland will get in the
playoffs
alright maybe New Orleans
maybe Sacramento hold it
see now you have to go Jack we realize
you realize how many teams and you
realize how many think about ahead of
them are not going to fall into that
looking for a little bit of a boulder
prediction then one of these three teams
is going to get in there playoffs
alright okay all right Charles if you
got your polo ready for me Ernie no you
know you can't start a bold prediction
with an if well hold on let me tell you
something they got to get in first
I will tell you this if the Portland
Trail Blazers get into playoffs they
will beat the Los Angeles Lakers in the
first round
oh oh that is bold
that is rule that is bold Wow I'm gonna
give you another one Ernie the teams
from five to nine one of them will be in
the NBA championship Western Conference
final five through nine hold it
what in the Western Conference for the
NBA championship in the Western
Conference Finals will be five through
will I'm one of those teams because
there's McLaurys them you've already
said the Rockets is gonna win the whole
thing the six you organized the Rockets
are gonna win no silly not even five you
did there's going to be a team without
home court is
Vantage get in because there is no home
court advantage that's my point
oh no I'm Cory Cooney and you guys down
there only one saying that Memphis look
out for and in this way this is what I
think about Ernie the reason that
separates championship is inexperience
playing on the road that separates you
there is no inexperience of land on the
road you don't have to go in Staples
Center in Game six and worry about a
closeout game traveling in there with
the hostile environment Dallas Memphis
everyone below them they don't have that
same anxiety that they have going in to
Staples Center and all those other
places they have a now the Lakers are
still gonna play the way they proclaimed
and so are the Clippers but the gap
closes because of the now the experience
is not needed guys with Portland healthy
now with Newark itch in there hasn't
played all year with Zach Collins who
hasn't played since October I mean this
is a totally this is a totally revamp
team going into the restart I don't do
anything go ahead jack you speak go
ahead Chuck no no go ahead Chuck four
three two one and back well and go ahead
see well Jack just said I think it's
really important if Nurik and Zac
Collins are healthy you know Damon CGA
gonna do their thing they right up there
with Steph and klay as the best
backcourt in the NBA no chick is
terrific
Zac Colin is terrific Whiteside got some
to prove he's got to be a free agent the
Lakers to me they got a couple injuries
but the treble has got to get in first
but I tell you what I'm really hoping
for in the Western Conference
I want to see the Houston Rockets
against the Oklahoma City Thunder in the
playoffs that is my dream come true
Ernie Chris Paul the best leader we got
going to go into Houston and kicking
their butt that would be one of the
greatest things I've seen in the NBA in
a long time and Ken right now that would
have that would have to happen a little
bit later in the playoffs because right
now Oklahoma City six they would play
Denver number three and Utah and Houston
four numbers four and five right now but
I know exactly what you're I know
exactly what you're talking about there
Chuck go ahead Shaq and Kelly to add on
what you're saying about having
experience when you have like home court
advantage your confidence level is
different specially playing at home so
you know the higher seats much must must
change their respect for the lower seats
because like you said there is no home
court advantage
there is no crowd and you cannot slip up
and cannot slip up cuz see these lower
teams they have something to prove and
they're gonna be playing much harder
than the guys at the high receipts
because again you know like when you
can't see Chavez when you add the crit
yeah you're right
I may be but you know when you have to
believe it's a game you don't go you're
not getting on the lane taking your
routes to the game you're not you're not
so it shouldn't be no fatigue you know
you don't have the you know wear and
tear and your body everybody's at the
same place and they're playing in a
ballroom they're playing in the ballroom
so you know I don't think I could do it
Chuck I don't know again Kimmy I don't
know how you feel but I need the crowd I
need people point in talking noise I
need to see kids I need to see you know
I need to look up and see you know Ernie
and you guys covering it so it's so you
know it's definitely gonna be a
different mentality saw our Kimmy I
agree with you that you're five through
nine any any of those teams can you know
advance so Kenny let me get your great
so it's you say six to nine or five to
nine will win the West and get to the
NBA Finals or get to the intricate to
the way in the Western Conference Finals
the token it will not be two teams with
home court advantage in the Western
Conference final because when you finish
your game think about this chat and
Chuck you finish your game you all walk
back in your uniforms back to your hotel
together this is an au setting this is
travel ball setting this is not a
setting that you're going on a plane you
got to think about it you got to read
your papers you got to hear about it
from your local media you're not hearing
any noise you're just coming and playing
so you're not a nervous that anxiety is
gone those lower C's those young and
experienced teams and for me John Moran
is not in his first year anymore he's in
his second year now this is like John
Luke Adonis is in his third year this is
this is a tournament this is not a
continuation of 2020 don't make mistake
and believe that these guys are
different well he's an NBA easy empty
punch candidate right now Luca daleks
what what do you mean
what do you mean well says when he gave
yourself five chances to get something
right he took five team that's not no no
you are talking I know you ain't talking
hey Kenneth Porcello Kenneth fratello
you like Mike Patel oh he takes 17 Shaq
wearing the same shirt
post-its back up there man it really is
go take a look at the East